sometimes the revolution is quiet
[Music]
that's certainly the case with formula e
launched in 2014 it's an all-electric
racing circuit that wants to capture the
excitement around one of the most
successful sports in the world car
racing evans cuts across
carbon fiber it's a plan that's at once
obvious and utterly audacious sure the
world's accelerating toward a greener
future spurred by the devastating
effects of climate change but success
for formula e means a tricky balance of
competing stakeholders we're talking
about automakers eager for new
technology would-be customers for
electric cars and of course finicky fans
and some of them are quite happy to keep
watching faster louder cars speed
through the world's greatest cities the
main power of sports is the fact that it
touches the heart the mind the souls of
its funds
definitely transport sector is one of
the big areas where the world needs
massively to improve
if you think about the 25 most watched
television programs ever 24 worst sport
events if you can use the power of sport
for a positive agenda that's really
powerful
[Music]
[Music]
i'm here in monaco which is known for
lots of things especially things related
to money it's also really known for its
role in the world of motorsports fast
cars in fact the monaco grand prix
happens on the streets just behind me
monaco is a tiny country the world's
second smallest in fact trailing only
the vatican it's tucked along the
riviera between france and italy and
when you think of monaco the first
things that come to mind are probably
james bond movies are the fast beautiful
cars
its status as one of the world's premier
motor racing stages came after world war
ii when formula one races began emerging
through europe the sport quickly
attracted both drivers willing to travel
the world to race and a rabid fan base
hoping to witness the spectacle in
person or on tv
while formula one races could initially
buy and race their own cars it also
attracted major automakers like
mercedes-benz alfa romeo and maserati to
showcase their latest and greatest motor
tech tech like active suspension and
carbon rakes that would eventually
distill down to cars we see on the road
today f1 also created legends like juan
manuel fangio lewis hamilton and of
course michael schumacher michael
schumacher leads the world championship
formula one's a huge sport in europe and
asia averaging more than 900 000 viewers
per race that's on par with some of the
ufc fights we see here in the states
with the audience growing partly due to
an unlikely source netflix
formula one is the ultimate competition
drive to survive a series that documents
the drama on and especially off the
track is one of the streamers biggest
hits in the past several years it's
drawn in a whole new generation of fans
tuning in and showing up to the races
and flicks are real bunch
every year legendary racers navigate the
hairpin turns in cities across the world
for throngs of fans perched on rooftops
and balconies just trying to catch a
glimpse
and a few decades ago alejandro agog was
a kid watching from his parents
apartment right here in monaco oh yeah
that was the first time i saw a race
from the terrace of our apartment where
my parents were living that previously
there was a formula one driver living
there no kidding so they were in the
drawers there were still some stickers
and some things and it was
great to have that memory
[Music]
alejandro is the chairman of formula e
politician turned businessman he found
his way to motorsport and ultimately ran
a team in 2007 in the second division of
formula one he went on to recruit
sponsors to the circuit and there he saw
an opportunity
i was at the time working around the
formula one business mainly with
sponsors in every
email it had some kind of concern about
sustainability about carbon
emissions so that's kind of when i
thought we should create a green version
of it
formula e is trying to ride and
accelerate a movement towards
sustainability that has urgently risen
in the past several years driven by
young activists like greta thundberg
part of a generation speaking out loudly
about the climate crisis
when i started my career 10 years ago
sustainability was something that was
kind of trendy but not exactly you know
like the the center of priorities
definitely formulae is much more than
like a race that is putting cars on
track but formulas is really a platform
that is here to showcase that is a
sustainable lifestyle that we're going
to be finding really cool really
exciting
this is julia pillay she's the head of
sustainability for formula e her job to
make sure the race circuit and its teams
are living up to the big promise of
helping solve that global crisis my
mission is to make formerly the most
sustainable sports possible this has not
been the first part in the world to
achieve that zero carbon since inception
phasing out of plastic on sites offering
vegetarian options to our fans trying to
use less lane to fly over or freight and
so on but how to go green and who's
leading the charge has become tricky
recently big companies including those
associated directly with fossil fuels
and their consumption have seen the
commercial value of moving toward being
more sustainable ford has pledged to
invest 30 billion dollars in electric
vehicles by 2025 having just spent 11
billion dollars this past september on
electric trucks and battery plants
volkswagen is more than doubling that
with the goal of investing 83 billion
dollars in the next four years and their
involvement has made alejandro's job
trickier some people will not get
involved because yeah but maybe they say
that we're doing this to look good i
think so many companies so many
corporations will do more for the
environment if they were not scared of
someone just coming and calling them
green washing you have to include
everyone on on the climate action if you
don't include everybody including the
big oil companies including the big
energy companies including everyone
you will not succeed
that's especially challenging when at
least part of formula e's success relies
on the investment of the major car
companies the relationships there have
been important but thorny at times the
car companies very much have a vested
interest in using the technologies that
formula e and its teams are collectively
developing their cars
motorsport is a sport where the driver
puts helmets they put specific
gloves so we can take more risks and
test very
ambitious technologies
this is javier pinon he's the technical
director for fia the governing body that
sits across both formula one and formula
e
the voltage for the usual ev car in the
street is something between 200 300 400
volts in a formulaic car it's close to
1000 volt for sure we will not be able
to take the part from the race car to
put it in the road car but the
technology inside will be the same
thanks to the motorsport the car
manufacturer can take more risk and
accelerate the research on the
development with the supplier but
keeping the manufacturers engaged via
teams has proven elusive both bmw and
audi earlier this year said they
wouldn't field teams in the upcoming
season claiming they have what they need
for now from a technical perspective to
help with their ev push
alejandro he's unfazed he said it was a
natural circle of life he'd seen before
in motorsports it happened in formula
one we had a few manufacturers german
manufacturers that came on board the
budget go up and then they say oh it's
too expensive and they leave for other
car makers formula e continues to be a
valuable lab especially as the evs seek
to make the jump from selling to
affluent customers in the west to more
emerging markets
the latter is where mahindra group is
focused
when we got into formulae we were really
thrilled with the level of competition
we got we were now for the first time
having a platform to show the quality of
our product against what was perceived
the best in the world
there's no reason why a mercedes or a
bmw and the indian market should come
under 250 premium this is dilbog gill he
runs mahindra's racing team
he's a veteran of that indian
conglomerate and deeply tied to sports
in general and motorsports in particular
when the opportunity to run the formula
e team came up at a dinner almost a
decade ago he volunteered
we were evaluating motorsport platforms
in 2012 after some amount of success
with the motorcycle racing and when
formula e came to us it sort of segued
really into what we were looking at in
the next 10 years in terms of our
mobility solution
so we took a call to participate
well i was with i think mahindra and a
couple of other people at a dinner in
delhi i just raised my hand and said can
i have the opportunity to run the team
and yeah sometimes you have to be
careful what you wish for because it
comes true and
that came true that evening
mahindra has a different market in scale
and potentially in terms of difficulty
india's power grit is notoriously
underdeveloped and unreliable and the
vehicle fleets aren't just mid-sized
sedans and suvs in many parts of that
country but small vehicles called tuck
talks interestingly today the largest
selling product which we have is
electric tuck tucks we are selling i
think maybe five to six thousand per
month and it's only increasing it's just
that we can't keep up with the demand at
this point of time when you talk about
pollution we're not only just talking
about smog and smoke but we need to talk
about noise pollution think of that loud
exhaust noise coming from a tuk-tuk
which started accelerating down the
street and now you have silent tuck
trucks or a silent bus going by it
tremendously improves the quality of
life
we did not join formula e for technology
we joined formula e because we felt it
was important for us to be a partner in
the sustainability effort so mahdra
plays in 20 different industries our
biggest industries are auto farm
equipment we have a real estate business
and a logistics business we then have a
solar business we've got a company that
recycles automobiles and we've got a
number of other businesses around
aerospace defense agriculture and a few
others while they may have a huge slate
of entities in its roster both mahindra
and formula e recognize the power of
sport in cultures across the world and
its ability to influence change
you've seen this as you say from
different perspectives both at michelin
and now being part of the formula e
team
what is it about sports
and sport that influences us do you
think i think the main power of sports
is the fact that it touches literally
the heart the mind the souls of its fans
whatever like is your sport you're like
a kid in front of the athletes you're
really like inspired by what they do
what they achieve
it's a sport where you've got not only
the focus on climate change but more
importantly it's a lot more fun because
the racing happens in city centers and
that will also have people start looking
at evs in a different light and say that
this is a great option for us if you
look at a per capita basis india is the
world's worst sporting nation 1.3
billion people we really don't have much
of record and support so i think through
mahindra through our various initiatives
what we're trying to do is
help people to move from viewership to
participation
and as a recovering politician alejandro
also sees formula e as an engine for
political and social change i just came
back from saudi arabia i was scouting
locations near neon you know used to be
very
very close very strict yeah and uh of
course there's still
still a long way to go but but i think
they're making
good progress especially with women you
know now women can drive for example
actually formula e was really part of
the change in saudi time because we were
the first event ever where women and men
non-related were allowed to just be
together and dance i mean we were really
proud to be able to be part of the
change
for alejandro formula e is part of a
broader portfolio of electrification in
sports he also runs extreme e that's an
off-road racing series that uses all
electric vehicles and the week we met in
monaco he was in town to take advantage
of another quintessential piece of
monaco the boating industry
the monaco yacht show was set to kick
off and one evening alejandro and his
team took over the monaco yacht club's
deck to unveil an electric speedboat
that will race around that harbor and
several other famous waterfronts
starting in 2023 we launched the race
bird the electric power boat that is
going to be the
boat that is going to race on the e1
world championship electric powerball
world championship this process is
starting now all around the world
that's why it's the best moment to
create a championship an electric
powerball championship to serve as a
platform for the industry to kind of
showcase what what is doing to the
carbonites you have to uh basically move
to electric mobility electric propulsion
in every space you have to move on the
cars you have to move on the roads and
you have to move on the sea
this is the boat
you see the foils
the propeller in the back the battery
will be behind the
the pilot the pilot goes there and it's
a designed by uh the designer sophie
horn right region designer
it's like it looks like a fighter jet i
mean it looks like a fighter jet
combined with the x-wing from star wars
yeah combined with uh many it's science
fiction
anyway how fast
60 knots
yeah they go fast now the real work
begins right yeah now the real world
begins
sponsors the calendar right and start
making everything real so in two years
or less than two years or years and a
half we hit the ground running
in the meantime there's the matter of
the upcoming season of formula e
alejandra will spend a lot of time
thinking about sponsors and teams and
across those teams they'll be thinking
about the next generation of technology
in their cars known as gen 3. there's a
lot of excitement around what that could
mean on the course and back in our
garages gentry we will reduce the weight
of the car something like 60 kilo the
biggest improvement is the fact that in
the very beginning of the formulary car
we
we the two battery pair race for 45
minutes
next year
in the end of 2022 we will use only one
car one battery
[Music]
a lighter car with one less battery
means the car overall will have a
smaller carbon footprint the battery is
also expected to have a faster charge
time that means it won't require a
battery swap mid-raise
it also means all of us could spend less
time charging evs and more time on the
road
then of course came the big existential
questions around the future of cars race
cars and naturally formula one and
formula e
alejandro's vision is crystal clear
someday they will be won
i see a convergence at some point
between formula one and formula a
because formula one is gonna it's gonna
lose its industry there's not gonna be
more combustion cars sold in the uk in
2030. so what's the point of a
combustion race in the uk in 2030 if you
cannot buy combustion cars right so
eventually formula one
is going to have to
do something electric
and the only way to do it is with us
because we have exclusive license from
the international federation until 20-39
for now the circuits exist in something
like parallel with the much younger
formula e gaining some ground if only
because it's in tune with the broader
global move to sustainability and the
stated goal of most major automakers to
ditch internal combustion engines
people perceive motorsport to be really
glam glamorous and stuff out there but
reality trust me is yes we are cleaning
up a lot of stuff i feel it's not a job
it's a mission and i'm not yet close to
even finishing it
you